vous a préparé un top 10 des images
cultes des années 90 et en dixième
position c'est philippe risoli vous
rappelez du millionnaire sur tf1 une
candidate qui est arrivé sur le plateau
complètement boury regarde c'est bon
baladeur étions 17 petits trous d'accord
oui je vais tourner la roue mais mon
mari va faire la roue pendant sa non tu
vas faire là où conan moscou là et copie
stone tu fais la roue bistrot à ma tante
à la route c'est pas vrai en mars
[Rires]
c'est bon je vous en ferai cadeau cette
raison que je vais tenir le micro à les
vues l'espère que c'est votre taille
j'espère votre paquet qui m'a entraîné
dans ce numéro 10 dans le viol rc lens
bon après ça il fallait faire tourner la
roue gauche me rappelleront gratter tout
le temps j'étais comme un fou je veux
absolument les 3 t il y avait trois
télés tia thiallier voilà obligé si
jamais vous que vous faites là très bien
comme on remet ça mais aussi bas merci
ça fait plus de pouvoirs avec l'équipe
du film
ah bah nan balle en bus pendant la pub
pas à esbly me font des petites
propositions si j'ai des petites du
temps aussi si je peux pas regretter
petra prix j'aimerais bien aussi que je
fasse un gars c't'un le prochain non
c'est pas vrai non c'est pas vrai
dorothée
il étudie manque à la télé c est ce que
les gens quand ils voient dans la rue
ils te disent encore tu que tu loft eu
des manques c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
c'est la première ça fait combien de
temps maintenant que tu est parvenu
vraiment et qu'une émission à toi ça
fait quoi ça fait autant mais je suis
sûr parce que c'est vrai que mine de
rien il ya des gens qu'on oublie et
dorothée dès ce matin je te jure j'étais
avec toute l'équipe en train de préparer
une émission mais bon il était comme
tout voir et tout quoi y'a dorothée
willa dorothée oui à dorothée quoi
dorothée va venir sur le plateau je te
jure c'est un truc de fou dans la rue tu
le ressens encore oui tout à fait c c c
ou fin ça fait très plaisir c'est très
touchant des états ont tort
t'as pas envie de refaire de la télé
c'est pas que j'ai pas envisager pas de
bonnes propositions à raclette y avoir
plein de propositions c'est sûr
mais je pourrais te suis sûr que ça à
temps franchement dorothée moi je suis
sûr qu'il ya plein de chaînes qui
voudrait avoir des producteurs moi alors
je produis côté je suis fan d'elle mais
qu'est ce que tu es amoureuse faire
dorothée qu'est ce que vous en de porc
ou ne pas non plus chez généra à vous
aimeriez ou alors vous aimeriez cher
dorothée faire quoi actuellement mais
auront pas parfait on dise il d'accord
mais il pose des novices il est comme ça
à ce qu'il faut de très bonnes questions
mais c'est pas le bon moment non mais en
fait il s'est cru sur rfm et c'était au
9e position est ce que vous rappelez
c'était jacques chirac avec cette image
qui avait fait rire la france entière
lors de la remise de la coupe du monde
98 gardes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'homme
syrie
[Applaudissements]
et vas-y que vous connaissez connaissez
les joueurs la tête de l'équipe de
france qui a gagné en 2018 ou pas si je
vous dis voilà je vous dis beinheim
tiens si je vous dis si je vous dis
traite blaise matthey une cuisine pas
mal de ballons et naulleau écolo quand
tu es sélectionné c'est grâce à g et 600
tr/min c'est un cerveau you en numéro il
y aurait eu cette chanson il aurait fait
il aurait été très bons en numéro 8 vous
souvenez de maïté allawi c'est notre
numéro avait ici avec moi qui tu es bien
il va falloir les assommer et les tuer
il entendu
bush par la chérie tu ne bouges pas ma
chérie enregistre ce lien hier la
buissière là ma biche wierre là il faut
pas trop grande retenue et où la somme
est un petit coup là pour chaque fois
que je la vois je suis en nombre assez
disait jean saint gilles sur ce super
bien imiter maïté julie je viens art of
quoi julien m'a dit mon préféré à toi
toi tu fais hyper me ryan a qu'à moi way
of te plaît fais la musique folle à me
situer laquelle si johnny cash
je fais trop bien cette chanson comme
étant mais tu fait mystère comment tu
fais bien mais c'est ouf
mais c'est hi-media n'a qu'à bois et le
papier mais qui est pas ça mais c'est
que je fais j'ai envie de te le demander
tout le temps tu fekitoa kamel la
bagarre la bagarre merci merci quand
même toi tu te laisses moi ouais en
imitation ouais bon moi c'est j'aime
bien michael jackson away the seas te
plait je te plaît ah oui tu fait hyper
mais on met la musique continue hélas
aidant mais attention à dijon ceinture
il dit il rigole pas les blacks pas je
te le dis mes décisions
il est trop content
vous avez remarqué vous demandez quelle
il attend qu'une chose c'est du moment
c'est comme ella ella jeudi et non il a
il a fait jeu comme michael jackson
la raison et audi en fait ils huppert
content de le faire maintenant c'est
parti
[Musique]
non
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as vu le talent non mais sans rire et
et regarder et les scènes de bagarre
dans ces centres est quand même temps
son top
non non on a un peu répété avec des
scènes sont pas mon cas mais loue ses
gentils alors elle joue alors on numéro
on devrait suffire c'était ça mon ami en
numéro 7 dans l'émission ciel mon mardi
avec christian clavier qu'on en dise
christian il est invité sur le plateau
il a invité schopperten d'amalie et
regardez elle est dans son monde la
pauvre gars je voulais vous présenter
andré gars qui est à votre droite qui a
je peux dire votre âge andré c'est andré
est ce que je peux dire veut est ce que
je peux dire
on leur égard
alors c'est pour la centième on se
rappelle c'est que les comédiens alors
on voit très championnat il ya gérard
judo dans le film qui avait joué dans
mais il se dit qu'il ya didier bourdon
et vous êtes voilà exactement barrez
vous êtes fidèles y en a trop de chance
surtout de jouer les gens qui nous ont
donné envie de faire ce métier c'est un
truc de fou
c'est fou dans la médaille à un casting
incroyable oui et bien mais parce qu'à
chaque fois vous entourez vous mettez en
fait au départ c'est vrai que le premier
qui avait joué avec vous c'était cgra
c'était girard exactement et après après
vous aviez pris et ici on me christian
clavier et après didier bourdon donc
chez moi y'a plein de guest bateau que
chantal ladesou drame email anderson ont
lembras d'ailleurs pas mais là j'espère
que nos gardes you want to me garde new
entrée dans le top 5 c'était laetitia
casta dans les top 5 des années 90
c'était le 13 mai 1999 avec un invité du
grand journal pendant le festival de
cannes et elle rencontre notre ami jamel
debbouze là c'était une belle rue à
limete 2004 la can tu vois quoi tu vois
quoi tu vois un un sage avec l
extraterrestre
la sas et la gaffe c'est le bigdil ça
les gens on est intime et ouais ça va ça
va j'avais embrassé sa casquette
c'est drôle et wayne avait le but ville
à l'époque avec big deal ah ouais c'est
vrai sur sûreté sur sûreté avec avec
lagaf fut des plus la greffe a disparu
non non il n'a pas du tout disparu il
est encore il est demain alors je vous
dis de manière strike sur ses huit
membres contre vous vous allez bientôt
disparaître avec nous non nous paie pas
une part dans mon coeur pas top 4
c'était l'école des fans présentée par
jacques martin était le 15 avril 1990
regarder
dix ans estelle c'est vrai ce que tu
m'as dit qu'est ce que tu m'as dit les
awa davis qui fait ces mois là
mais elle boit du whisky nouveautés je
vous dois regarder où j'ai pas je joue
j'ai l'impression que vous qui fait
toutes les images des années 90 un peu
tanné de voir ça c'est sûr mais ça
rappelle tellement de souvenirs vous
regardez toujours la télé ou pas oui
enfin beaucoup sert à fond à fond à fond
à fond
elle va très bien mais je vous venez
nous voir quand vous voulez quoi je vous
vois à la télé déjà c'est bien de venir
chez vous peut venir chez vous numéro 3
c'était sur antenne 2 dans l'émission
des chiffres et des lettres est l'un des
candidats monsieur van damme était très
très inspiré jour là regardez vous avez
ri van damme
en fait avec enculage les mouches
exclusivement
bien entendu
ce que j'aime et ce qu'on aime dans des
chiffres et des lettres
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on ya un mois
un petit peu genre litigieux et sont
12es vote pas regardé il y avait
également broutage soir il vole pas il
va la halle et a loupé à ses jours moi
c'est pas moi c'est le cas je suis pas
je suis pas là dedans en numéro 2
ce que vous vous rappelez du journalisme
ladislas dr house sur tf1
il est très connu à son célèbre coup de
gueule ou qu'on voie des airs en 91 et
ça on ne s'en lasse pas c'est le numéro
de lot des 9 90 on voit les gens voient
pas ne veut pas mettre ça derrière pour
ha et la caméra aussi s'il te plaît
voilà tu le mets derrière le truc comme
ça jusqu'au trou du cul par hasard et on
arrête de l'ernée les bordels je vois
pas où est la caméra nous sommes
football quand elle était à lumière est
terminée et je voulais en numéro 1 c'est
une image qu'on a découvert en fait dans
touche pas à mon poste
bien après et tout le monde hallucinant
contre chypre à 106 matches pour nous la
piste numéro 1 des images des années 90
et dans fort boyard c'est trop patrice
tabac oui quand pas de mecs plafond et
menif le j appartiens
cette image allait passer c'est
l'anarchie genre le mec tranquille ja
passe partout il est des personnes bien
sûr ça passe très mal en entrant qu'elle
passera tout mais c'est une histoire de
ouf j'ai pas compris que cette image
soient passées inaperçues
pour nous c'est le numéro vous croyez
que j'invente ont regardé la plus grand
bien cette image qu'il est méchant
[Applaudissements]
chez vous vous voyez ça n'est ce pas
parce qu'on ne peut pas la voir depuis
le début que cela que je le voyais du
nord mon avis on a dû rêver est vrai
qu'il a fait déraper le chômage l'année
nicox georges bel attrapé ce match c'est
lui qui contraire ils sont brouillées
wec ce qui t'arrive mais toi tu vas voir
toi et on voit qu'ils sont brouillard
dont il arrive fait tu vas voir je t'ai
l'émission prémices août voir tu voulais
pas regarder ce qu'il est méchant
[Applaudissements]